Станіслава та її колеги активісти хочуть
бути помітними навіть попри те що не всі
будуть раді їх бачити
поки ми розмовляємо з Станіслава яка
допомагає організовувати Харківський
Прайд отримує новини про протест проти
ЛГБТ в іншому районі міста
така ворожість для неї не нова у нас
демократична країна тому Якби я не бачу
нічого поганого в тому щоби люди
виражали свою думку в такий спосіб це
набагато краще ніж там переслідування
погрози і побиття людей яке також
трапляється під час після прайду
активістів насправді більше хвилюють
російські ракетні атаки це одна з причин
чому прийшло набагато людей інша причина
багато хто покинув місто але також Дехто
з них воює з росіянами
вирізані силуети представляють тих кого
немає
але ці фігури були тут недовго
минулої двох годин а деякі з вирізаних
солейтів вже відсутні але вони неподалік
Як ви бачите тут я можу витягти один з
них для вас
тут написано це могла б бути Марічка але
вона евакуює поранених на фронті ті хто
це зробив і досі тут І здається не
соромляться камери
зараз я вважаю що взагалі не той час щоб
агітувати отаке я ж кажу було б більш
логічно якщо замість отаких пострілів
отаких чоловічків райдужних поставили
монументи і встановили фото хлопців які
віддали
найменше хоча б життя за Харків за
Україну в цілому більшість символічних
фігур не дочекається 11-ї вечора коли
настане комендантську година їх забрали
знищили або зіпсували українське
законодавство досі визнає лише шлюб між
чоловіком і жінкою але опитування
показують що більше ніж половина
українців підтримують одностатеві шлюби
близько чверті проти це є інтимні речі і
яка б там культура не була який якої в
орієнтації це не було Це не має значення
щоб виносити це не люди Вони ж нікого не
ображаються
[музика]
кожен має право кохати того і кого він
хоче кохати тим часом за більш ніж
півтори тисячі кілометрів від Харкова
українські
ЛГБТ активісти долучаються до прайду що
пройшов цього літа вулицями Берліна
у традиційному 45-му прайді на вулицях
німецької столиці взяли участь понад
півмільйона осіб український трак з
написом бій pright like Ukraine майже на
початку колони перше до підтримки
українського трака офіційно долучилися
посольство України в Німеччині для мене
важливо приєднатися до українського
lgbtq громади в Берліні тому що це все
про свободу
[музика]
це універсальна цінність яку українці
сьогодні захищають
захищають на фронті захищають як
неурядовці захищають як громада
це також про рівність і на фронті всі
рівні коли ти борешся за свободу
і наші хлопці і дівчата і наші
представники lgpt Community вони всі
Брати по зброї на фронті і ми стоїмо за
Європу за європейські цінності
законопроект Про цивільні партнерства
який дозволить реєструвати одностатеві
шлюби був внесений до Верховної Ради
України на початку цього року це був би
серйозний крок для всієї твір-спільноти
особливо тих хто воює на війні партнерка
станіслави Аліна військова вона Щойно
приїхала у відпустку додому зі свого
підрозділу вона не приховує своєї
сексуальної орієнтації від товаришів але
каже що реакція була на однозначною пара
влаштувала імітацію весілля з друзями У
нас є фотографії У нас є відеоряди Ну з
нашого перфомансу як виглядає як
церемонія але ми все ще не можемо
одружитися в Україні важко до цього
ставитися як ну типу як до чого до
особистого ну свята тому Ну ми все ще не
можемо одружитися вона також знає як і
всі інші твір військові якщо її поранять
або б'ють її партнерка не матиме права
ухвалювати рішення щодо неї
Ми хочемо юридично захистити нашу сім'ю
і для нас для того щоб планувати взагалі
майбутнє потрібно потрібен якийсь захист
від держави і якийсь визнання від
держави того що ми є і ми сім'я
ця родина бореться за майбутнє України а
також за своє місце в ній